hello and welcome to cloud on-air live
webinars from Google cloud hosted every
Tuesday my name is Elise Roche and I am
on the data analytics marketing team
working around social and environmental
impact so I'm especially pleased to
welcome you all to a special session
that we're hosting today in light of
Earth Day we have with us Linda Mallards
the CEO and founder of farm logics here
to share her story about her
organization what inspired her to start
it and how she implemented GCP solutions
in order to scale her business as a
heads up we'll be taking live questions
throughout the webinar so feel free to
submit them online
we have Googlers on standby to answer
them and we'll also be hosting a live
Q&A at the end of our presentation so
with that let's get started
so before we dive into the amazing work
that Linda and farm logixx has done to
date I thought it'd be interesting to
rewind a bit and share a brief history
on Earth Day so Earth Day began with an
ecological tragedy in 1969 over 3
million gallons of oil spilled off the
coast of Santa Barbara killing over
10,000 animals in the region from sea
lions to dolphins to seagulls
among others now by that point America
had been somewhat primed for a new
ecological consciousness with the 1962
publication of Rachel Carson's a Silent
Spring it was in that work that she
discussed the impact of DDT and other
pesticides on the environment on all
living things from crops to the pests
that afflicted those crops to ecological
systems animals and humans now at that
point the US Senator Gaylord Nelson
actually decided to mobilize on that new
ecological consciousness and coming off
of the the movements of the 1960s and so
in 1969 in light of that ecological
tragedy in Santa Barbara he proposed a
televised national teachin on the
environment which took place on April
22nd millions of Americans rallied that
day to support new responsible
environmental practices leading to the
creation of the EPA and also clean acts
later enacted by Congress from there it
grew into a global movement
so fast-forward 40-plus years to the new
and ever-growing challenges that we face
with the environment one of which is the
concept and the opportunity of
sustainability at which food is at the
heart of the matter
industrial food systems are the common
denominator
they sit essentially as a common
denominator across a variety of factors
that actually directly drive or
contribute to climate change to name a
few there are carbon emissions
pesticides and pollution deforestation
and also water supply and here's a taste
of what's at stake one third of all
human caused greenhouse gas emissions is
caused by the global food system and
agricultural practices are responsible
for around 74 percent of greenhouse gas
nitrous oxide in the United States now
what that does is that actually
contributes to the rising global
temperatures across the world with
respect to pesticides and pollution
agriculture is the largest contributor
of ammonia pollution and other nitrogen
compounds which compromises our air
quality and pesticides can be
transported and runoff and groundwater
and can result in toxic levels for
humans and wildlife which then
compromises our water supply and with
respect to deforestation 75% of global
deforestation is caused by agriculture
and that's especially problematic given
the stats that I shared around carbon
emissions here we are emitting even more
emissions into the atmosphere and
depleting the natural resources that act
as a counterbalance the carbon stores
also known as trees since 1960 one third
of the world's arable land has been lost
through erosion and other land
degradation and with respect to water
supply to support agriculture rates of
groundwater withdrawal are increasing
relative to water source or punishment
in the United States that is we are
taking more water from the earth than
the earth can naturally replenish and by
2025 1.8 billion people are expected to
live with absolute water scarcity now
that does not just impact agriculture or
food that impacts our potential for life
as water is crucial to life
so with all that being said where does
farm logics come into play they're
continuing the legacy of Earth Day by
fostering these new responsible
environmental practices they're changing
the way that we eat and they're also
supporting local farmers and that all
begins with the story of Linda at age 40
she discovered the thrill of the
outdoors and the beauty of nature she
was selected to join the USA triathlon
team for her age group and began racing
across the country it was on these
well-worn paths with a Sun beating down
upon her back that she had the
opportunity to meet farmers to hear
their stories to hear their their strife
and their struggle their inherent desire
to live a green and healthy life and
also be compensated fairly for the work
that they do
she made an instant connection and it
was from that point that she in in 2012
later on actually founded farm logics
naturally at her kitchen table a place
of community family storytelling and
nourishment she applied her experience
in the futures industry developing
technology platforms to the agricultural
system in order to build and scale
sustainable supply chains just one year
later farm logics became the farm to
school solution for Aramark Chicago
Public Schools and over 2,000 locations
overseeing the sourcing of over 20
million dollars worth of local foods now
today farm logics provides food
technology services nationwide with an
eye towards corporate responsibility
then actually offers auditing services
they also manage active procurement in
over 15 States and maintain an
e-commerce platform for buyers and
sellers now these are all bullet points
in a time line but there is a narrative
arc that unites all of the above and
that is a story of revolution there's a
story of change and a story of impact
there's a story around not only changing
the way that we eat and empowering local
farmers through integrated cloud
computing solutions provided by GCP but
also bridging an increasingly large gap
between people and food between people
and nature and between people and our
home that is the earth and that is truly
in the spirit of Earth Day so with all
that being said I would like to welcome
Linda to begin her presentation hi thank
you so much Elise and thank
so much Google for having me here to
tell our story this is what a
sustainable supply chain looks like but
before I get into the details I want to
go back and tell you a little bit about
racing in the connection with the
farmers I'm some of the racing that I
did was called adventure racing where
you race in wilderness locations and
with nothing but a pack on your back for
48 to 72 hours and you are in Mother
Nature big with all its glory and all
its challenges but at the end of the day
I was able to get home put my racing
clothes away take a shower and sign up
for my next race I learned through
meeting the farmers along the way that
farmers don't have that opportunity they
are faced with the power of Mother
Nature every single day so drought or
rains or bounty or not that is their
struggle and that is something that I
related to very much I found that really
we have disconnected we had become from
our food system we and myself included
have really lost our connection that
there are many who actually grow our
food and I realized that they are our
heroes and I wanted to help them and
that is how farm logics came to be I
started out as a CSA from my kitchen
table and and it developed into this
chart that you can see now basically
when local food was this is actually a
real chart about how farm-to-fork works
at Chicago Public Schools Aramark
Chicago Public Schools which is one of
the largest school districts in the
country and they have the largest farm
to school program that we run and
basically when we came on board you'll
see that they have four distributors
there on the chart each one of those
distributors was told perhaps to source
a local apple and in doing that they
would source from a state perhaps maybe
from several farms but basically you had
four different sources going out and
looking for that food and a lot of the
data ended up getting lost and we
realized that and it was really hard for
Chicago Public Schools to be able to
tell any sort of story so what we did
was
created a technology platform we call it
aggregate that allows farmers to post
their availability online so that large
institutions like Chicago Public Schools
can see what local food is available and
actually order it I put a red box around
logistics aggregation because that's the
role that we play we come in there and
basically allow the schools universities
healthcare systems business Dining's
such as maybe your cafeteria here and
sports venues to be able to all order
from the same farm and but we turn
around and place a single order with
that farm the technology places a single
order or so to the farmer they know
they've sold an entire trailer truck of
apples um they may not know exactly
who's buying from them but that's okay
we're really helping them stay on the
farm and helping future generations stay
on the farm we then turn around and the
technology sells that product to the
distributors so the distributors have
just one customer which is farm logics
technology platform and managed by our
technology platform and really what that
does is it keeps the distributor from
having to manage multiple small farm
relationships which is very complex and
was hindering the movement so we kind of
sat there in the middle we call it
aggregate and aggregate really
streamlines the whole process from there
we do our data collection which is the
chart that you see here and run metrics
and those metrics are run nationally and
by location they're used by the
government food service companies
distributors really to figure out where
is this food going and what is selling
and that really helps the farmers
determine what to plant on the far right
you'll see this is a single day serving
of carrots it comes from will Allen's
growing power in Milwaukee Wisconsin
thirty six thousand pounds that is one
day's lunch and it feeds three hundred
and fifty thousand kids at six hundred
and fifty schools so really to grow the
local food system you really have to
think about scale and meaningful impact
and this is how we make it happen so
basically responsible sourcing at scale
requires equitable access to healthy
foods so we went really as we started to
scale went beyond went beyond the farm
to school and start
bringing that food into the home and so
last year we actually won a grant as a
team with the Chicago Community Trust
and the kinship foundation it was called
the food to market challenge and it was
to create a CSA where Chicago Public
Schools were actually pickup locations
for food that could be brought into the
home and not just enjoyed at lunch at
school we now have several schools as
pickup locations and we've expanded that
into the healthcare sector and we have
now five hospitals in Chicago that are
pickup locations we also work with a
retailer Peapod and we work with them in
multiple markets running a CSA for them
that's everything is farm identified so
consumers can order a CSA online and
have it delivered to their home to
support local farms we also have Farm to
School campus and workplace programs
that basically allow people to enjoy
local foods when they're away from home
our consumer custom ecommerce technology
reestablishes the fact that we have a
choice I think what started to happen as
the local it what started to happen when
big AG came and and we started to scale
for global production and we lost our
choice and we started being told what we
we were going to eat and what was
available and I think beginning with
Earth Day and then eventually the rise
of the farmers markets consumers
realized they really had a choice and if
they use their voice they could have
access to healthy food away from home
and so really our e-commerce technology
provides choice and acknowledges that
the consumer has there's an incredible
variations like a thumbprint in what one
considers local and sustainable and our
e-commerce allows you to shop by what's
important to you and everything we do is
fully transparent at the time of order
we provide Farm profiles videos and full
source transparency for storytelling
this is an example of an online program
that we run for Peapod as you can see
it's called the local firm box and the
lower right is an example of the box we
also run other programs with other
products such as meats everything comes
with a recipe and farm profiles as well
and then we provide again the metrics on
everything so you're looking at not just
produce
inorganics you're looking at sustainable
and humanely raised meats you're looking
at organic dairy cage-free eggs bakery
and other responsibilities source
products so we basically have three
aspects to our technology we started out
with e-commerce and then we have
launched open fields in 2017 open fields
basically takes six billion dollars
worth of purchasing data and we scrubbed
it by eighty five sustainable attributes
so those attributes run into categories
such as ecologically sound Fairtrade
human health locally sourced and even
seafood and basically what we do is we
provide this custom searching experience
through open fields so somebody can go
online and say show me what is 50 miles
from me that is organic show me humanely
raised meats with in my state we have
custom definitions of local by mileage
radius state combinations of state or
even state programs we also provide
compliance with sustainability programs
such as HD stars which is the American
Association for sustainability in higher
ed real food challenge and health care
without harm these programs have
requirements and auditing that is
required and so our our search tool
allows you to search for compliant
products for those programs and just a
plug for Google here on at the bottom
you will see that in our platform also
is the ability to generate Google Maps
to show the location of the farm and it
also displays the mileage to the
location of the person searching so if
you think of open fields as we consider
open fields of possible and the possible
is really what's out there that's
available to purchase but has not been
purchased by someone else but not
necessarily purchased by the person
searching open fields reporting is a
post transaction product that we have
that allows any location that uses our
services to be able to run metrics on
their sustainable purchasing often
you'll find a distributor or a company
that is I'm selling a product will
provide reporting but when you really
think about it like some day like the
University of Virginia which is
here we'll use 2030 different sources so
to get that whole holistic reporting you
know you really need to do data
collection from your entire from all
your purchasing so we basically take
that data collection and then we provide
our clients with a dashboard from which
they can tell their sustainable story
and again just like you can search by
custom metrics you can run your reports
by custom metrics as well so this is
basically a stars report for the
University of Virginia all their
locations all their purchasing and one
thing to note is that since there is no
single definition for responsible
sourcing in the food space these reports
can be run multiple times from multiple
reasons some people might want to run a
full sustainability report and the stars
report and we provide that complete
flexibility we also come off ur the
ability to do very large scale metrics
oops
metrics across an entire enterprise the
entire country etc aggregate is our
e-commerce platform you had looked at
the flow chart for that and so aggregate
this is what it looks like when a
purchase is actually happening an
institution would go online to place
let's say the apples and that you see on
the left the buyer would see the price
the pack size and which is important to
institutions things are sold in 20 pound
cases usually they would see the firm
that is growing the product they would
see the miles to their location to see
if it complies with their definition of
local if you look at the top you will
see that there are tabs for days of the
week what we do is we use this as an
advanced ordering system where multiple
multiple institutions 6070 perhaps in a
region will go online and order by the
week a month in advance and then what we
do is we add up all of that demand and
give a single order to affirm with what
they need to have available each week
and then basically on the other side of
aggregate distributors are made aware of
when the product is coming in and when
the customer is expecting it believe it
or not aggregate is a tool that is being
used now by
the nonprofit world we just formed a
collaboration with the National Farm to
School Network and will be launching a
pilot in June in Illinois and basically
what will happen is we will be using our
reporting tools to gather information on
their Farm to School activity in
Illinois and then we will identify
common products that all school
districts are buying and create an
aggregate platform for them to scale the
Farm to School movement in Illinois
through the use of aggregate so we're
very excited about that behind the
scenes in aggregate our tools for farms
to become food safety compliant one
thing to know and in the law is law and
um and the Food Safety Modernization Act
requires farms and will require farms
regardless of size to be able to comply
with food safety so basically they will
have to say when they harvested their
their product the date that they packed
it who picked it up when it was
delivered and then what source it came
from and that could be a farm or even a
field so aggregate provides this
behind-the-scenes for the farmer and we
provide it free to any farmer that works
in our system basically but also of food
hubs and cooperatives can use it to
manage their own business almost as a
small erp system basically then from
that data labels can be generated and
those labels and can be put on the boxes
with bar codes for full compliance with
large distributors so basically we allow
that small farmer to play in a much
bigger space by providing them with the
food safety and this is super important
there was actually a as you know last
week an e.coli break ecoli breakout and
it's interesting they've identified
where that romaine lettuce actually grew
but I think you can tell that it was a
very large grower because there were
outbreaks in 11 states that tells you
that that's a large grower when that
product is getting into 11 states so
when you do purchase locally and you
know where that food is coming from you
get a label like this on your box and
and it's in it's just a much more
contained issue so that's another reason
to purchase local
and then just bigger picture all of this
activity gets entered into our database
obviously again more than a million
dollars of a billion dollars of
sustainable transactions have run
through our system and that continues to
grow but we're able to turn around and
deliver metrics to large food service
management companies distributors
nonprofits in the government as well and
we do that by a variety of metrics that
you can see on the screen location farm
SKU spend food category and product so
just real quickly I'll talk about the
timeline because we're gonna get into
the tech a little bit now in 2013-14
I personally launched this at my kitchen
table using three off-the-shelf up tools
and I called myself oz behind the
curtain because it looked great but it
was a lot of work and then in 2014 I'll
be started to create a proprietary
program in my sequel and we launched our
for products cloud slot open fields
aggregate and made of data and that's
not a misspelling that was my
grandmother's name in 2017 we migrated
to Google bigquery for our reporting
platform and are currently operating on
multiple clouds in 2018 we have plans to
integrate to Google cloud sequel and API
and then in 2019 we have plans to
integrate to elastic search and Google
retail solutions so a little bit about
how that looks right now you'll see the
my sequel on the upper left in the AWS
environment nightly now we export that
data that goes to the cloud server and
down into bigquery where we do manual
file exports of large size for you know
enterprise metrics and then we use
jaspersoft and power bi for for
individual metrics and reports that you
saw similar to the University of
Virginia currently we're using algo Lea
for our search engine and jaspersoft for
our reporting in addition to Microsoft
power bi and we were one of your first
beta customers for bigquery to Microsoft
power bi
and by the way we use the we use the
consulting firm aptitude in Chicago to
do this this was our recommendation to
move to big career and we're really
appreciative they did a great job
okay so 2018 sees us starting to migrate
from my sequel and so on we will be
doing that and we're actually doing that
currently I do go cloud server and what
that's gonna allow us to do is I'm
really scale our business on my sequel
was really never meant to run six
billion dollars worth of purchasing data
it's really was meant to build an
e-commerce platform and we didn't really
see this direction when we launched the
company so Google Cloud sequel is going
to be able to allow us to scale and then
that data will go into bigquery and also
go into our aggregate commerce system so
we're really excited about that the next
thing number two that you can see on the
chart is we also are going to start
accepting contributed data and that
would be purchasing data from outside
sources small vendors that don't make it
into the system farmers that have
product to sell
so we basically are transitioning to a
full true marketplace 2019 you see us
also transitioning to Google
elasticsearch which would possibly
replace al boliya for us so that there's
more full into integration we probably
also use your Cabana tool and then also
transition to using Google cloud and
bigquery for our e-commerce as well
which would be a whole environment for
us and the idea of that is very very
exciting so why did we why did we choose
Google cloud platform
well aptitude chose it for us first but
why do we love it the open platform
integrates seamlessly with our my sequel
database so there were no issues making
a transition the migration was quick and
easy
we started in late November and we were
done by the holidays so it was wonderful
it was about 30 days and we had complete
visibility that was not possible with my
sequel the data prep is intuitive and
transparent and there's many of us that
access it and use it bigquery is
compatible with a wide variety
reporting solutions that were beginning
to experiment with which is exciting the
flexible structure allows us to grow
when the time is right the managed
services and security allow us to grow
faster than our learning curves
sometimes an elastic search and retail
allows us to run our apps from a single
database
so just at a glance you know obviously
technology scales all sorts of things
and but in our space what is really
exciting instead of scaling a movement
it's feeling a true movement to be able
to put together and scale and really
have impact not just on local farms but
equal access to healthy foods and all
neighborhoods in rural neighborhoods
urban neighborhoods we all go to
restaurants and eat local food on the
menu but it's exciting us when we see
that food moving into low-income
communities communities that don't have
grocery stores when you see people
having access to healthy food and their
health improving so basically what
Google is doing for us is allowing us to
scale a movement and so we see
technology as a tool in that regard and
we're very grateful I'm just some stats
on us we've saved one point five oh one
point five thousand oh yeah fifteen
hundred metric tons of co2 since
inception and our technology allows
buyers to source by custom mileage
parameters small farms producing fruits
and vegetables for fruits and vegetable
consumption usually don't use harmful
pesticides that is usually used to grow
food for not for humans so so the small
farmers that you see on the roadside at
your farmers market usually don't use
those pesticides and so our set our
system now identifies criteria twelve
criteria for ecologically sound
certified organic foods etc that support
these small farms um one thing that's
super important is that the rise of
superbugs in this country is due to the
animal antibiotic resistance compounded
by the antibiotics that we eat in our
food it isn't because we have taken too
many antibiotics it's because we eat
many antibiotic
and there are a lot of poultry producers
and pork producers who are now realizing
this and really transitioning and and we
commend them to being fully know
antibiotic ever it's actually called nae
and our system identifies products that
are nae and we actually run in any
program for Chicago Public Schools and
then the average age of the American
farmer is 58 and what we really want is
we want the next generation to want to
stay on the farm we want farming to be a
viable occupation we want there to be
abundance and and we want there to be
hope and so really that is why we are
here and basically what our farm to
school programs do are from the
cafeteria programs or CSA programs
really are to create that real scalable
model for the future so that we all
thrive and that's our app well thank you
Linda so before we dive into the Q&A
I've actually prepared a few questions
myself for Linda
so to start how would you define local
and how does that definition come into
play when serving communities around the
United States yeah so um well my
personal definition really doesn't
matter because local is in the eye of
the polder so for some people it might
be what's down the road what's within 50
miles of me what's in my state what's in
the state's touching mean that's
actually somebody's definition the state
of Rhode Island's definition is the
state of Rhode Island so really what we
do is we allow folks to both search and
purchase by what their definition is and
then for the reporting and metrics to be
run by what our clients definition is
for instance earmarks definition is 250
but a lot of their clients it's not
their definition and so we really allow
for that custom definition that's great
and originally you started out by
creating sustainable and local food
systems
now you collect national scale food data
how does that data drive consumer
decisions well I think what's really
interesting about our database is that
we did not realize when we started
collecting this data but there's a lot
that the consumer is vine that's already
local and sustainable and they didn't
know it
so I think what's happening is it's
exciting for people to see oh I didn't
realize that that was grown in Michigan
I didn't realize that that chicken that
I'm reading is has no antibiotics in it
and so really what we're doing is we're
creating opportunities for education and
an education and an educated consumer
will drive the movement yeah
and in today's complicated food system
how can the average person drive change
how can someone navigate the variety of
labels and classifications to make more
environmentally conscious choices well
I'd say that obviously there's a lot of
labeling that we see and there's a lot
of labeling we see that isn't true
and so I think that there's legislation
being done by that and that's a very
very important work but as consumers I
think what we have to do is use our
voice I think that what's really
interesting is we see the loudest voices
on college campuses today and really
what's happening is rather than demand
local food on a menu they are demanding
it everywhere they go they want it on
their college campus they wanted in
their dorms they want it eventually when
they go out into the world they want it
at work they want it in and you see
people even health care people wanting
to make food choices when they're in the
hospital anywhere they are and so I
think that on what we can do is keep
using our voice because everybody's
individual voice is getting pretty darn
loud yeah it's also and looking ahead to
2030 at the 17 sustainable development
goals developed by the UN sustainable
food systems are necessary to achieve
those goals like zero hunger and
responsible consumption what would you
say our critical practices that must be
continued or adopted in order to reach
those goals well I think what's really
important is to recognize the entire
supply chain needs to be involved in
order to I was reading those goals this
morning and in order to eradicate
poverty and hunger and these very large
issues that we have disease you really
have to engage the whole supply chain
and we have to work together and we have
to collaborate we can't nobody can be
thrown under the bus often we see large
companies in this space being thrown
under the bus just for being large
companies but it's large and such
institutional buyers and distributors
that have the ability and the customers
to buy this food and move this food and
so we all have to play together and
that's where how we see they'll change
yeah absolutely well that is certainly
an inspiring vision for the future and
now with that I'd like to thank you
again and move to the live Q&A we'll be
back in less than a minute
so now we have some questions from the
audience to start what was the initial
prototyping process like for aggregate
that's very fun it's so fun and makes me
laugh reading that question that was
five years ago so I'm basically and we
used just an off-the-shelf ecommerce
platform called Volusion you can go to
Volusion about we still operate some of
those today and basically but it was
really interesting because typical
ecommerce cannot sustain the growth
mostly because you look at pictures of
product and a lot of people buying and
then institutional space when I look at
lists so then we brought we developed a
list on another platform and then we
would move that data over to Volusion
and I mean I'm telling it was very funny
so I would say that on it began with
very very basic ecommerce and then what
we really did is we waited until we knew
where all the supply chain gaps were and
what existed out there before we create
we created our own platform so but that
was what the prototyping was it was
barely you've come a long way
and second question is what's the
greatest issue facing farmers today that
you think technology can solve well it
depends on which issue they face there
are tons of tech solutions out there in
the growing space to help them I
actually just read an article about you
all on that Google was doing some
research on being able to alert farmers
of you know future weather issues that
might impact them and how they can
protect themselves which is terrific
so we see a lot of tech solutions on the
growing side to help help protect
farmers and help them scale help them
harvest more efficiently etc I think
that what we the space we occupy and
where we think we help and there's not
that much participation there on the
technology side right now is in bringing
their products to market we're a firm
believer that farmers need to focus on
growing that's what they're great at and
we like to tab to our technology take
care of the rest
and the last question that we have from
the audience is what our farm logic says
most important metrics and KPIs well I
would say you know what again it's in
the eye of the beholder and what they
want to report on but I would say I
think what's most important is when we
create that baseline for a customer when
we're in the corporate responsibility
space working on a project where we
develop that baseline and say here's
where you are today
and where do you want to be and and then
we help them not only measure but also
identify where there are gaps and rooms
for improvement and so some of that is
going to be you know maybe you should
unchanged for seafood purchasing
practices or you know obviously produce
is less expensive than sustainable meats
and so maybe you want to add some of
that into the mix and so really it's
it's really the metrics are the baseline
and then the goal and the achievement
that's great well those are all the
questions that we have from the audience
would like to thank Linda again for
joining us today in our special session
today on Earth Day so thank you again
and stay tuned for more cloud on cloud
on air webinars coming your way every
Tuesday
you